you should just be yourself right i mean  i take pride in the fact that i didn't  give you what anybody thought or said  i was just going to be myself and you  know on my dad's son  on my mom's son my brother's brother you  know  um alexis alyssa and jake's father  tiffany's husband  this you know i just try to do the best  like everybody else i mean i've been  blessed  you know like i say all the time i'm the  luckiest guy in the world and i just  try not to take it for granted i try to  enjoy every minute  and i think now as i've gotten a little  bit older i try to give a little bit  more back than i have before  and and try to help more people and i  you know in terms of whatever  if anybody else finds themselves in my  position just enjoy the moment enjoy  every minute